okay so andrew garfield spent most of
2021 playing the werewolf game with the
entire world
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
i promise you i am not the werewolf are
we gonna see you toby and tom in the new
movie
i want to get really clear i want this
is this the unequivocal yes no answer i
did not get a call
now i was kind of hoping he'd continue
to deny being in the film and even on
his deathbed would be telling people
he's not the werewolf however the actor
has now opened up about his part in
spider-man noway home and he's also
teased what could be coming in the
future with the character throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down all the interviews that he's given
over the last couple of days whilst also
talking about our theories on what could
happen next with the intro out the way
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so spider-man no way home was the
biggest movie of 2021 after of course
red notice apparently and it capitalized
on over 20 years of storytelling after
it brought toby and andrew back as their
versions of the wall crawler throughout
the year we watched andrew getting more
and more exhausted as people constantly
asked if he was in it several leaks
happened and not even a doctor strange
spell could make us forget some of the
times that he got caught in 4k finally
though he can now talk about what's
happened and we have a brand new
interview with entertainment tonight
that i want to break down first i'm so
happy that i get to talk about it now
like first and foremost i am a fan so
when amy pascal and kevin feige and and
john watts asked to have a word with me
and talk to me about an idea and they
and they pitched it it was like i was
the fans in the audience watching it on
screen for the first time with like the
three spider-man across universes are
sharing a frame together and like your
little head just explodes so like that's
the main thing in me that i'm that i
feel about it and then the fact that i
get to be one of those people wearing
the suit next to my actual spider-man
hero toby maguire and the brilliant
incredibly talented heartfelt funny good
sweet perfect spider-man of tom holland
and then i get to be the middle brother
and i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother i absolutely love how
giddy he is in this and if you are
following his portrayal in the amazing
spider-man movies you might remember
that garfield actually opened up about
worshiping the webhead when he was a kid
garfield was a super fan of the
character and in all honesty i think
he's my favorite on-screen spider-man
seeing the three together at the same
time side by side kinda reminded me of
just how good that he actually was and i
think that he gave such a good
performance that everyone could now
appreciate what he brought to the role
now in the interview he went on to talk
about the themes of being a hero and how
he and toby played a mentoring role to
tom holland's version garfield said the
theme of mentorship and how these two
people across the universe were the only
ones that could really fully understand
what this young man was going through
and that was really important to us as
well that it was really about tom and
tom's character tom's peter tom's
journey as the center of that now when
we think about the movie there's very
much the theme running through it that
peter could end up going down the dark
path that they did both at one point
discuss how the big death in their life
changed who they were as a person and
it's almost a warning to tom holland's
version now because of this toby's peter
stops tom from killing the person that
was responsible for ant-may's death him
being the person that somewhat led to
the death of the guy that was working
with blimp marco and killed uncle ben
haunted him a lot also i hate that
record man having to jump through those
hoops of explaining uncle ben's killer
every single time does my head in so i
hope he just steps in one day and says
it was always him just keep it simple
yeah make it him anyway toby doing that
kind of steered tom away from that one
direction but andrew stepping in was a
lot more subtle gwen stacy dying was
very much what stopped him from pulling
his punches and thus him stopping mj
from falling to her death also meant
that tom wouldn't be angered about
losing the love of his life in the
interview garfield also revealed that he
and toby snuck into a screening of the
film alongside director john watts they
said they initially just wanted to stay
there to see what the reaction was like
when they returned but that they ended
up sitting through the entire film
because hey it's just that good
mcgarfield also did an interview with
variety and he shared some
behind-the-scenes info on it he said i
think the first time we were all in the
suit together it was hilarious because
it's like just three ordinary dudes who
are just actors hanging out but then
also you just become a fan and say oh my
god we're all together in the suits and
we're doing the pointing thing we would
have deeper conversations too and talk
about our experiences with the character
and to have amy pascale who's seen
through nine movies including
spider-verse it was a revelatory
experience for her realizing how much
life and time she'd given to this
character that was beautiful and
profound and that's a really nice tidbit
there and i know amy pascal gets a lot
of crap but she has very much guided the
character for a long time and even
though not all of the films she's
created have been universally loved i
think she's had way more hits than
misses now garfield went on to talk
about improvising lines in the film and
he confirmed that the moment which he
says he loves tom and toby was indeed
ad-libbed this is such a great part of
the movie and it also feels like he's
speaking from the heart when he delivers
it also i love you guys and if you've
enjoyed the video so far we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day also make sure you spoil
yourself with some heavy supplements
available online right now you some of a
[ __ ] now when discussing the future of
his character andrew had to remain
pretty tight-lipped but he did say the
following i mean yes definitely open to
something if it felt right peter and
spider-man those characters are all
about service to the greater good and
the many he's a working class boy from
queens that knows struggle and loss and
is deeply empathetic i would try to
borrow peter parker's ethical framework
in that if there was an opportunity to
step back in and tell more that story i
would have to feel very sure and certain
in myself and the fact that andrew has
said he's open to return and sony being
sony i can definitely see him coming
back sony aren't exactly warner brothers
and they do listen to their fans
especially if they know they're gonna
make money pretty much the entire mcu
deal hinged on people complaining that
spider-man wasn't a part of it and i
think he can pretty much guarantee that
they'll find a way for things to work
sony also of course want more control of
their ip and i can potentially see us
getting tom staying in the mcu whilst
andrew goes off and continues his own
franchise this could be more connected
to their other properties like venom and
just in the same way that miles morales
will be interacting with a lot more
visions of spider-man he could too i'd
absolutely love to see him united with
spider gwen and if they brought emma
stone back then that would be a license
to print money now morbius was
originally supposed to release at the
end of the month but it was pushed back
because of this a lot of people have
theorized that andrew will be shooting
additional scenes for it but my spoiler
sense is kind of tingling on that bit
and by spoiler sense i mean [ __ ]
radar now you have to remember that sony
already knew andrew was going to be in
the movie for several years so i think
that they would already have things
planned out i think andrew will have
probably already have shot scenes if
he's gonna be in it and i think the
delay was more to do with the pandemic
and giving noah home a bit more room to
breathe at the box office now i do think
that he probably will show up in mobius
and if not then we right beyond that
though in terms of the mcu i actually
think that everything is building
towards secret wars this is something
that we reported on after avengers end
game and there have been rumors for a
while that it's coming in case you don't
know secret wars basically involved the
multiverse being cracked open and
alternate worlds had to battle for their
survival there were tons of different
versions of the characters and with the
events of loki happening the way they
did i think that's what we're building
towards this will allow andrew to come
into the main universe to fight for his
world's existence and yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens now as
for toby i kind of think he might show
up in doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness you might remember that we
reported a while back that fergie
actually got ramy back to somewhat also
help secure toby for no way home with
the director and actor being so closely
linked in their career and the
multiverse also ripping open i can see
him potentially showing up in that film
and it would be great to see him back in
the end though i am a bit annoyed with
andrew as he spent ages denying it
constantly saying that he wasn't in no
way home then the movie comes out and it
does well and all of a sudden he's like
yeah i mean it i always was it's clout
chasing yeah it's clout chasing i tell
you that and i don't like it anyway you
know we love to end the videos with a
crap joke and there it is but
that's all we have to talk about right
now for the movie and of course also
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
you punk now we are in competition right
now and giving away three copies of an
mc boxer of your choice on the 30th of
january and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the ending of spiderman
now at home which will be linked on
screen right now i feel like it's one of
the best endings to a film ever and i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it as well
so make sure you go head over there
right after this if not thanks for
sitting through this video i've been
paul you've been the best and i hope you
enjoy your weekend take care peace
you